hi everyone my name is David Seidman I'm
a product manager in Google cloud and
today we'll be doing a deep dive on data
protection capabilities in compute
engine and persistent disk so what we'll
be covering today will be a general
overview of this area and then some
depth on what we do around backup and
disaster recovery a new capability we're
introducing called disk cloning
capabilities for high availability
workload consistency and then a set of
best practices that you can apply to
your workloads so this is a 300 level
session there'll be some technical depth
on some existing features some new
features that we are that we are
announcing and again in the context of
best practices how to choose the right
tool for the job so that a particular
feature or a particular even feature
flag is the right choice for whatever
whatever your scenario is so terms of
our our mission and and and who we serve
our goal is to serve the most demanding
workloads so workloads with demanding
recovery point objectives recovery time
objectives workloads that demand
flexibility whether it's around cost or
data sovereignty or performance and the
capabilities that we'll be talking about
today are a foundation for critical
services both inside of Google and also
across many different industries you can
see here some examples Energy retail
media finance the list goes on so this
is a foundation that that we've been on
and then also customers use across
across many different industries so as a
high-level overview starting with
scenarios can kind of think about think
about the world in terms of some major
major functions or scenarios for backup
and for disaster recovery we have highly
reliable high performance snapshots and
we'll be talking more about the
if the goal is flexibility for data
mobility copy data management we'll talk
a lot about what we mean by that but for
example very quickly getting data from
production to staging or very quickly
moving data from a production workload
to a kind of a scratch environment where
you can do auditing or verification disk
clones as a recommended feature for that
for high availability we have a product
that's been GA for since early 2019
called regional persistent disks we'll
talk a lot about how we think about H I
and then for application consistency we
have two new features Google machine
images and guest flush a guest flush is
actually an existing feature but we've
made some enhancements to it that will
be we'll be talking about okay so it's
more depth on snapshots so snapshots
provide resilient backup for failures
that could be within the region or
within the surface so what we mean by
that is if you have a persistent disk
running in a certain region a snapshot
allows you to extract that data and the
snapshot is created in another region
and it happens to be stored actually in
different service from from persistent
disk sort in GCS so that means even if
there's a failure in or some sort of
outage or accidental issue with with
your disk or with that region or even
with PD over all the data is highly
protected and there's a lot of options
here so for example by being able to put
a snapshot in any region or multi region
you could optimize for cost you can
optimize for resilience for example
putting your data on a different
continent you can optimize for
performance by keeping your snapshot
close to the disk in the same region
optimizing for how long it takes to
create and restore that snapshot or data
sovereignty so if you need to keep your
data in Montreal or in a sort of a
certain jurisdiction in Europe you can
choose exactly which location the
snapshot is stored in I talked a little
about some of the agility if you have a
disk and you wish to take a snapshot of
it that's not
we'll go to any region or multi region
you select and if you have a snapshot in
a region or multi region and you wish to
restore it to a disk that can directly
be used to create a disk in in any
region terms are thinking about
performance for these for these
workflows it's important to know that
once you create a disk from a snapshot
those discs will run a full performance
full speed as soon as the snapshot
restore completes so whatever i/o
throughput latency that you need for
your critical workloads will be there
once the disk is available and and
attached so you don't need to worry
about for example you know having an
attached disk which sometimes it's
performing and sometimes may not be
performing well and in general as a
basic principle the more data that
you're moving to create or restore
snapshots the longer it will take if you
have a very large disk that you're
taking a snapshot of for the first time
or that you're restoring that will take
longer than an incremental snapshot that
you're capturing more frequently with
just small data changes so let's talk a
little about consistency so as a new
area here that we'll be talking about
something that's coming soon and
something that's now in beta we want to
ensure that in addition to the crash
consistency that snapshots provide if
you need some additional level of
consistency either across disks or up to
the level of the guest for your act for
your application workload there's
options for that so the guest flush flag
has been available for a long time for
snapshots but for Windows only
integrating with with windows of ESS
what we're introducing coming soon is
support for this flag on linux and the
way it works is it integrates with
script hooks so within the within the
guest that has the disk attached that
you're snapshotting you can create or
place a script that executes before the
snapshot is taken and after the snapshot
is taken so that can provide a lot of
flexibility a lot of control
inside the guests so for example you can
qui us an application before the
snapshot is taken and then you can
unquiet shot is taken
you can trigger automation you can run
scripting to figure out what kind of
applications are running on the guests
so that you have visibility for let's
say any cataloging or additional
additional verification you want to do
for those workloads how exactly what
those scripts do and how this flag works
for those scripts on Linux depends on
the behavior of the script themselves so
the consistency or other behavior is
entirely up to those scripts and this
can be provided either by something that
you roll your own or you can work with
your your favorite backup or disaster
recovery provider that we partner with
for those scripts another feature in
this same category is Google machine
image this is now in beta so this is
available for for anyone anyone to use
Google machine image that sometimes
called GM eyes provide a point-in-time
image of a full instance so that means
VM configuration and data from multiple
discs so if you're running a workload on
a VM and the data on multiple disks that
are attached has some sort of dependency
on one another let's say data as well as
the transaction logs for that data that
should be kept in sync when the Google
machine image is captured it's captured
consistently and atomically so this is
great for instance replication
backup/restore
or even putting a GMI and into the
marketplace again it captures the disk
data as well as the metadata
consistently and you can use this in
conjunction with guest flush so that you
get consistency both across the disks on
a VM as well as up into up into the
workload ok let's talk about a new
feature that we touched on a little in
the in the introduction we are now
providing capability we call disk
cloning so the reason that we've
introduced this this capability is
there's often scenarios where you may
have data on a disk let's say it's in a
running disk in production and you very
quickly very quickly want to create a
new disk from the data on that source
disk so today there's a few ways you can
create disks you can create a blank disk
you can create a disk from an image you
can create a disk from a snapshot this
provides an additional way so for
example if before you had a disk and you
just wanted to create another disk in
the same zone you would have to create a
snapshot and then restore the snapshot
down so you're moving data basically up
and up and down through just a temporary
sort of placeholder snapshot where you
may not in practice actually need that
snapshot to be to be a durable backup so
just moving that data can be could be
very slow if you're moving let's say you
know tens of terabytes of data that
could take a very long time this clones
are optimized for performance and for
this exact scenario where again what you
want is a disk at a particular a disk in
that same local zone where you're
running that that workload and you can
expect this to typically complete in a
minute or less so we talked about
scenarios of quickly bringing up a
staging environment from production if
you are running a workload or a database
and want to run some kind of
verification let's say on or do some
sort of export of data rather than
running that export and sort of walking
walking the disk while it's still
attached and supporting your production
workload you can now clone it attach it
to a second VM and then do whatever
verification or processing or exporting
you want on a completely separate cloned
system for these scenarios this is also
a cost savings so if the goal was to
create a second disk anyway now you're
saving money on the snapshots that are
that are no longer needed the cloned
disks are in many ways ordinary disks so
they're live attachable fully
provisioned writable writable disks they
run at full speed there are some
constraints so I mentioned
this clone must be in the same local
zone and it also needs to be of the same
type so the same disc skews so if you
have an SSD disk you can clone it into
an SSD disk not an HDD disk and this is
also designed for high frequency so you
can clone a discovery 30 seconds and
again you can expect the actual cloning
process to be high performance this is
just a visual of one of those flows so
again if if you're taking those one-off
snapshots today for a high value disk
just to create additional discs again
for devtest
export audit now those one-off snapshots
are not are not necessary and another
scenario if you are let's say scheduling
downtime for a workload in order to do
an upgrade now you can have much more
protection with higher performance so
the scenario here would be take a clone
of a disc save it as a rollback point so
if you're worried about the the upgrade
let's say being unsuccessful or
corrupting the application in some way
and you really want that safe intact
rollback point of before you try to
change change your application you would
clone it stop the workload do whatever
upgrade is needed verify and if the
upgrade succeeds you can discard that
clone you don't need it anymore
but if it fails and you want to get your
upgrade running and you want to get your
application running again as soon as
possible just swap in the clone disk and
restart your workload and you're back to
to that healthy state so again this
optimizes this flow where otherwise you
would need to copy the data up and down
to a snapshot to get back to that that
saved a pre upgrade free upgrade state
okay so let's let's switch to high
availability so regional persistent disk
is our offering here provide some basics
on sort of what it is and how it works
and then we'll talk about how it
supports different kinds of failure
scenarios to provide high availability
so regional persistent disk provides
synchronous replication between two
zones in the same region so what that
means is that as a workload is writing
to a disk there's a second replica of
that disk in another zone and we ensure
that that data is committed on on both
sides so what that means is that if you
have a single failure let's say you have
a network disconnect or a sustained
outage in a zone your recovery point
objective can be met at at zero zero
data loss
so versus let's say using snapshots
where you may take a snapshot then if
your workload is destroy it or has some
sort of outage you can always restore
your snapshot but the amount of data
loss that you would have with the
snapshot scenario would be the amount of
time that elapsed between when you took
the snapshot and and when the outage
occurred here using regional persistent
disk your RPO is zero this is designed
for maximum availability so what that
means is let's say that the your
failover zone becomes unavailable we
still maintain the availability of the
workload in that primary zone so and we
favor maximum availability which also
means that if you have an outage in one
zone let's say in your in your failover
zone your data still running and intact
with no data loss in your primary zone
well you'll want to take some
mitigations we keep your workload
running even when one of those zones
goes down the other thing about
emphasizes this this offering provides
additional replication between two two
zones but every persistent disk is on
persistent disks meet or exceed three
copies within each zone for additional
durability so just a little more detail
on the failure management that I was
that I was outlining so you could
imagine two scenarios
one is if you have a failure in your
primary a chaise owned we recommend
using health checks to determine if
backends are responding to traffic so
that's the way you would detect if there
if there's a failure
if there's a failure in your primary
zone and you want to fail over in the
secondary zone the recovery time needed
to attach that disk to a fellow three
failover VM will typically be a minute a
minute or less so again that's that's
the data is replicated to the secondary
zone and you'll be attaching attaching a
VM to to that to that to that disk it's
actually one one logical disk that's
represented in those two zones the
actual RTO that you achieve will depend
on how you manage your VM so for example
if you have a standby a hot hot standby
VM that's running all the time versus a
VM that you need to start that of course
will affect your your recovery time
objective in this in the scenario where
failure occurs in the secondary H a zone
if you're thinking about a primary
secondary pair then again you're the
data that you're continuing to maintain
and you're available primary zone is
there but you've lost your HEV
protection because your secondary zone
is now is now down so in that case the
best practice in fact we would always
recommend this best practice is to use
scheduled snapshots so scheduled
snapshots can ensure that you're at
least bounding your recovery point
objective even if you have that
secondary zone become unavailable so
that if there is lettin a second failure
let's say there's a regional outage or
some some other sort of some other sort
of loss
you now have snapshots as an additional
layer of protection the other thing
that's important to know about regional
persistent disk is catch-up and failure
recovery is automatic so let's say
there's a network outage in replicating
to a second zone once that's resolved
the replicas will automatically be
caught up and brought in sync okay so
let's let's talk about some best
practices for these for these features
so the first point we made in the
context of clones avoid temporary
snapshots whenever possible so again we
know that for scenarios where the goal
is to create a new disk immediately for
the scenarios that we that we have
described
copying back and forth to a snapshot is
a waste of time and also a waste of
resources and an unnecessary costs so
you can use clones for much higher
performance and cost saving benefits the
second best practice is if you want to
very quickly create new discs especially
a cross region images are the best are
the best resource for that so again if
you have a single data source and you
want to very quickly create large
numbers of disks and including between
regions images are optimized for that
scenario so there's local caching that
we do in persistent disk in any target
zone that you're where you're starting
to create new discs and you'll see much
faster high-performance disk creation
the third best practice that we talked
about in the context of regional
persistent disk but applies applies
really really everywhere is the
scheduled hourly snapshots for backup
and disaster recovery so we have a built
in scheduled snapshots capability this
can this is a great way to limit any
risk of data loss if there's against
some some outage or or disaster or or
human error the other thing to consider
is some customers like to take daily
snapshots which is great if that
frequency can be increased so that
snapshots are taken let's say every six
hours or 12 hours instead of daily that
will lead to smaller uploads rather than
uploading all of the changes for the
last day and that will support faster
snapshot creation times okay so
hopefully this will be useful as sort of
a reference chart and thinking about
scenarios features and and what their
purpose-built for so again snapshots we
really think of as optimized for long
term data backup you can find pricing
information on our website and
information about exactly how we manage
full snapshots and then incremental
chains of those snapshots as you take
more snapshots from the same disk
and if what you need is geo redundancy
or long-term backup it's it's the best
option if the goal is high availability
regional persistent disk is
purpose-built for that it's not built
for backup so again if there is if a
region is somehow completely unavailable
or destroyed in some way you would need
snapshots in addition to regional PD to
have that durable geo redundant backup
but regional persistent disk gives you
that zero RPO for a single failure and
that very low RTO disk clones also not
intended for disaster recovery those are
optimized for efficiently and creating
new disks in the same in the same zone
from a production workload so again we
talked about the examples of export
offloading forking data into staging
very frequently optimized for that
purpose and then as we look at Google
machine images and the guest flush
option those are optimized for
consistency so whether you need
consistency across multiple disks that
are working together to support a
workload on one VM or whether or not you
want consistency up into into the guest
itself again for application quiescence
or verification or additional
information that is for additional
information and control that's only
available inside of inside of the guest
and again looking at it from the
scenario perspective just to recap
backup and dr we recommend using
snapshots for efficiently moving moving
data within within a zone so to bring up
new workloads
we recommend disk clones and then for
high availability regional persistent
disks and then we have these two options
depending on the nature of the
application consistency that the that
you need so thank you very much and we
look forward to hearing your hearing
your feedback